local officials being forced to step up
as president biden drops the ball on our
nation's borders this as ice reveals the
suspect charged with killing texas
corporal charles galloway was in this
country illegally ken paxton texas
attorney general joins us now not only
was he in this country illegally
attorney general he's had a criminal rap
sheet since the 1990s he's wanted for uh
murder um i believe in el salvador as
well he's a bad guy he was in this
country how is that possible i know that
you're not going to get any help from
the biden administration uh without
federal help how do we make sure that
this doesn't ever happen again
we'll see that's the problem it's going
to happen again we predicted this it's
going to happen all over the country
it's not going to just happen in texas
it's going to happen all over the
country and so it's it's sad to say that
the biden administration knows that as
well they've been working with the
cartels allowing them to transport
people here cartels are making hundreds
of millions of dollars every month and
some of the people coming in our country
may be terrorists some may be criminals
just like this
look this is a situation that obviously
is impacting your state tremendously but
it's not just your state at this point
that is being impacted ice agents have
been forced to coordinate literally the
travelocity for illegal immigrants all
around the country as new video shows
secret overnight flights full of
illegals take a look at this video
i get the whole
secrecy and all this [ __ ] but this isn't
even about my
no but what's what's the big secret
everybody knows it's happening
like the government
in fact a.g paxton one ice agent telling
fox news this is just the tip of the
iceberg this has been happening since
february of last year this happens all
the time in cities and airports all
around the country how is every american
not outraged by this
i don't think a lot of americans really
understand this is going on they i think
they they're shocked when they realize
it's the federal government that is
sneaking these people in the middle of
the night whether it's on a bus in texas
and i can tell you i've talked a lot law
enforcement they tell me they see them
get off in the middle of the night in
our cities
when they unload it's but it's happening
all over the country and i don't think a
lot of americans can believe that their
president is behind this but but that's
exactly what's going on
well vice president kamal harris she was
in a honduras yesterday to attend the
new president's
inauguration she also apparently
addressed the root causes of illegal
immigration but she says don't expect to
see results anytime soon listen to her
here
the work we need to do is going to be
work that will manifest over the long
period of time hopefully not too long
but certainly not overnight the problems
that we need to address are problems
that did not occur overnight and the
solutions if they're going to have any
impact will not occur overnight
so she's busy addressing the root causes
of illegal immigration she says it's
going to take a long time to fix
anything in the meanwhile ice is um now
releasing people with criminal records
into our country so why is she even
trying at this point to address root
causes when there's such a pre-pressing
issue happening here right now
well i do agree with her it's going to
take a long time the way they're
approaching this the reality is she's
wrong about the amount of time it took
to have this happen because
illegal immigration numbers went up i
think triple from the time that trump
was in office to the time that biden was
in office and that started occurring
really quickly because they changed
policies and they stopped following
federal law so the reality is we're
gonna get more crime we're gonna get
more drugs we're gonna get more covered
more people are gonna die
because this administration doesn't just
not care about immigration they're
encouraging it
they certainly are and i know that texas
is trying to do all that they can um
but it's an issue that's not going
anywhere clearly and it's one that
affects people in states across the
country
aj thank paxton thank you so much for
joining us
thank you have a great day you too